at precisely 9 A.M each morning the
muffled voice of a woman can be heard
greeting her comrades across the border
The Source this wall of 48 speakers
built in 1967 then proceeds to broadcast
a series of pop songs
[Music]
the comrades she's referring to are not
Korean but Chinese
and the woman the late Taiwanese pop
star Teresa Tang
this three-story propaganda station lies
on the Northwestern tip of one of
taiwan's kinman islands just three miles
from the Chinese Mainland and an hour by
plane from Taipei
kinman in other words lies on the most
fraught edge of an already fraught
region
in fact not once but twice has it
successfully repelled Chinese invasions
in 1949 and 50.
but while the Korean border has largely
remained Frozen in Time A combustible
buffer zone that few dare cross this one
has changed dramatically
today this is what life looks like in
the Sleepy Villages of kin men home to
about 100 000 people
on the other side of the narrow channel
that divides them and visible to the
naked eye this is the Chinese city of
xiaomen population 5 million
as China's economic and military
strength has grown Taiwan has been
forced to confront its vulnerability
kinman would be among the first and
easiest territory to capture possibly in
a matter of hours
simple pragmatism therefore has slowly
transformed this Frontier from a highly
fortified Garrison to a kind of
commercialized Museum
once home to one hundred thousand troops
a mere 3000 remain today
in their place 984 000 tourists most of
them Chinese arrived in 2019 alone
spending about 360 million US Dollars
and then returning by way of a 20-minute
Ferry
the broadcast station still plays
propaganda but at a much lower volume
and only for the benefit of tourists
meanwhile this tiny patch of land little
more than a rock is one of its few
active military bases
its usefulness was recently questioned
after it struggled to shoot down a small
consumer Chinese drone
now make no mistake an attack on
taiwan's main island of Formosa would be
no easy feat
the landscape is mountainous the 80 mile
Journey treacherous and the weather
frequently uncooperative
still the extreme vulnerability of
kinman is a powerful reminder of
taiwan's dependence on the elephant in
the room the United States
sponsored by nebula the streaming
platform created and owned by creators
for just two dollars and fifty cents a
month you can get access to our entire
catalog of early bonus and original
videos
in August 2021 President Biden surprised
everyone when he told ABC quote we made
a sacred commitment that if anyone were
to invade our NATO allies we would
respond same with Japan same with South
Korea same with Taiwan
at best some argued this was evidence of
Biden's declining mental acuity
at worst it was intentional and
therefore irresponsible even dangerous
others celebrated this long-awaited
momentous announcements
but nearly everyone seemed to agree on
one thing
this was a big deal
here's why
in 1949 the Chinese nationalist party
led by Chiang Kai-shek lost the Civil
War to the Communists and fled to what
we now call the island of Taiwan
despite this loss the United States
continued to recognize it as the sole
government of China for the next 30
Years
during that time the two countries
signed a mutual defense treaty promising
to protect one another in case of an
attack
American troops were even stationed in
Taiwan
that treaty ended in 1980 after the U.S
switched recognition to the People's
Republic on the mainland
in its place Congress passed the Taiwan
Relations Act which obligates Washington
to do two things
first sell the island weapons quote
sufficient to maintain its self-defense
capability
and second maintain the capacity to
resist any force that would jeopardize
the security or social or economic
system of the people on Taiwan
in other words Biden was not strictly
correct
the United States does not have the same
sacred commitment to defend Taiwan as it
does with Japan South Korea NATO and
others
it has the option of course but not the
obligation
still perhaps he's simply misspoke as
many were quick to point out it wouldn't
be the first time
then the same thing happened just two
months later
and again in May
each time the White House issued a
statement saying nothing had really
changed
and each time they became less and less
persuasive
finally in September Biden went a step
further clarifying that American troops
would respond
after four increasingly specific
statements in a row no one could write
these off with a straight face as just
mistakes
politicians analysts and journalists
announced the death of America's
four-decade-long policy of refusing to
say whether or not it would defend
Taiwan called strategic ambiguity
established by Jimmy Carter and upheld
by every president since
but not so fast
when Carter signed the Taiwan relations
act in 1979 America didn't promise to
defend Taiwan that much is true
less well remembered is that it also
didn't support Taiwanese Independence
it didn't even believe it or not oppose
its unification with China in fact it
was widely assumed that it eventually
would
Washington's attitude was this is for
you two to figure out
the only thing it actually opposed were
unilateral changes to the status quo
in plain English anything that wasn't
peacefully agreed to by both sides
now this may ring Hollow
surely America wasn't just some neutral
disinterested third party
but the ultimate test of whether it's
sincerely committed to the status quo or
just using it to undermine its communist
adversary is does it only oppose China's
attempts to change the status quo or
does it also oppose taiwan's
the answer is that whenever Taiwan has
even flirted with the idea of
Independence America has sprung into
action
far from cheerleading for that outcome
it moves to prevent it by occasionally
intervening in the country's Democratic
politics to a degree that would make
many Americans uncomfortable
George Bush for example criticized
taiwan's president for making relatively
minor symbolic moves toward Independence
in the early 2000s
the Bush Administration felt this so
important that it defied intense
bipartisan outrage for taking China's
side
what's truly amazing about the status
quo is how long it's persisted despite
being no one's preference
unification is one of China's oldest and
most important political projects
the people of Taiwan are stuck in
diplomatic limbo denied the very real
benefits of international representation
and most Americans would prefer this
vibrant democracy receive the full
recognition it deserves
but the guiding principle behind
American policy since 1979 is that
deeply unsatisfying as it is the status
quo is the least bad alternative
the way it's maintained this delicate
balance for 44 years is by creating room
for both China and Taiwan to believe
time is on their side
the trick is that no individual Chinese
or Taiwanese later needs to immediately
unify or declare independence
respectively
they just can't afford to lose that
future possibility
on any given day forcing unification or
declaring independence would be an
extremely risky Gamble
thus both leaders have an interest in
delaying
put differently the two sides of the
strait do much of the work of preserving
Peace by wearing rose-colored glasses
seeing what they want to see
Washington's only job is to paint a
picture abstract enough that each side
can simultaneously interpret it in a
favorable self-interested way
what makes this simple task so
challenging is that it's a continual
process
whenever America perceives a change in
this balance either from Taiwan drifting
toward Independence or China gaining in
strength it steps in to re-establish the
equilibrium
Reagan spelled out a version of this
principle in a 1982 memo saying the
quantity and quality of arms provided to
Taiwan should be conditioned entirely on
the threat posed by the PRC
in other words the U.S hasn't written
Taiwan a blank check to militarize it
sells exactly what's required to
maintain a comfortable balance of power
nothing more nothing less
and in the last decade or so the balance
has shifted unmistakably in China's
favor
First America has successfully
stigmatized Independence in Taiwan no
prominent politician has advocated for
it in years
and second not only has the size and
strength of the Chinese military grown
but the party has taken a more
aggressive tone under Xi Jinping
add to that the Russian invasion of
Ukraine and you can see why Biden might
feel the need to act decisively to
restore the balance
so in the most straightforward sense
what he said was new and significant
in the broader context of America's
attempts to maintain a balance he was
only recalibrating a policy unchanged
since 1979.
one thing to keep in mind is that
strategic ambiguity has never been
official U.S policy
this term has always been an unofficial
description of how journalists and
academics perceive U.S policy
the Taiwan Relations Act doesn't State
we may or may not defend Taiwan it just
doesn't say anything
besides ambiguity and Clarity aren't
binary options they're opposite ends of
a spectrum
the answer to a question on 60 Minutes
is less credible than a comment made
during an official speech Which is less
credible than a commitment formalized in
a treaty
ultimately the question would the U.S
defend Taiwan can only be answered by
the sitting president
and because the particular location and
circumstances matter Biden was
effectively speculating out loud about
his own anticipated reaction
anyone who claims he shifted to a policy
of complete Clarity is either
overlooking or presuming the answer to
difficult questions
like how would he respond to an invasion
only of kin men
it's and other so-called indefensible
outlying Islands were specifically
excluded from its Former Defense treaty
hypotheticals like these may sound
tedious and trivial but it's exactly
these red lines or their absence that
determine a commitment's credibility
to summarize Biden has no doubt moved in
the direction of clarity but there
remain plenty of uncertainties
but hold on
more important than what Biden said how
he meant it or why is what effect it has
we don't need to assess anyone's
intentions or debate whether this
represents a change in U.S policy to
determine whether these actions
increased or decreased the likelihood of
conflict
so self-obsessed as the world of U.S
foreign policy that it's easy to forget
something extremely basic
China already assumes it would defend
Taiwan
military strategy 101 dictates that the
people's Liberation Army must expect and
prepare for American intervention
anything else would be dangerously
Reckless
and indeed many of the weapons Beijing
has invested most heavily in are aimed
at in the words of the Pentagon denying
third party intervention
you can probably guess the identity of
that third party
in other words it's very unlikely that a
verbal commitment from Biden would
fundamentally alter beijing's calculus
whatever it planned to do before it
probably still plans to do now
but it's not so much the content of the
president's comments that likely worries
China it's their tone
tellingly the Chinese foreign ministry's
reaction was to warn against sending the
quote wrong signals to the separatist
forces of Taiwan Independence
to translate it was the implication that
concerned China not so much the words
themselves
since the very beginning of the two
countries relationship China has been
deeply suspicious that America is only
using Taiwan as a way to undermine it
armed with this underlying distrust it's
extremely sensitive to any indication
that America is abandoning the status
quo and moving in the direction of
Independence
ironically the last 44 years of Peace
proved that all three parties want the
same thing
at least they're willing to tolerate the
but Biden's comments inadvertently feed
into beijing's suspicions
fearing this is the beginning of a trend
toward Independence China tries to
credibly demonstrate its concern by
reacting assertively
the U.S then interprets these often
quite dangerous moves as a challenge to
the peaceful equilibrium and acts to
offset the change which again prompts
China to react
it's this spiral of escalating reactions
that most worries experts
it's how both countries could Veer into
a conflict that neither one wants
as Cornell professor Jessica Chen Weiss
has said the challenge is figuring out
how to deter China without provoking it
into action or validating its fears
fortunately we're not stuck between the
choice of either capitulating to China
or needlessly escalating tensions
for over four decades America has sold
Taiwan billions of dollars worth of its
best weapons proving that it can
maintain peace without inciting War
remember the time-tested approach is to
ensure that a tomorrow perpetually feels
like a better time to act drastically
than today and B both countries are
reassured that their worst case remains
improbable
one way to accomplish the former is to
increase the cost of an attack by
investing in the right defenses
currently Taiwan is incentivized to buy
a few expensive and flashy things like
submarines and fighter jets
purchases like these help boost morale
and project an image of toughness to
voters
but experts consistently argue a more
effective approach would involve a large
number of little things
this strategy sometimes called a
porcupine or overall defense concept
could include laying mines building
anti-ship defenses or stockpiling
resources in case of a blockade
none of these actions would cross any of
China's red lines the U.S already sells
weapons but they would help strengthen
taiwan's defenses
now there is another elephant in the
room we should address
Biden's recent comments are
representative of an unspoken bipartisan
consensus that a Chinese invasion is
inevitable or even imminent
if has slowly become when a mindset that
encourages quick and sometimes Reckless
action
reality is much more complicated much of
the evidence supporting this belief is
the result of misunderstandings or
mistranslations of Chinese speeches
only China would initiate a war and
therefore only by uncovering the
specific forces at play in China can you
truly understand the probability of
conflict which is why I've made this
video doing just that
in it we take a closer look at all the
evidence for and against The near-term
Invasion and get to the bottom of
China's timeline it won't be available
on YouTube until August
but you can watch it right now on nebula
our independent streaming platform where
you can also find my six-part exclusive
series China actually
there we explore topics like how Chinese
censorship is both more and less
pervasive than we often imagine and why
the country came to dominate the world
of the rare earth metals ubiquitous and
modern technology
nebula is also home to other fantastic
Originals like real life lore's modern
conflicts explaining the wars we often
hear about but rarely have time to
untangle
in great cities City beautiful walks you
through how Shanghai built the world's
largest metro system along with other
wonders of the modern Metropolis
nebula is the absolute best place to
watch my videos there are no ads
sponsors algorithms or upgrades just
great videos all the time
now normally nebula costs five dollars a
month but you can get it for fifty
percent off just two dollars and fifty
cents a month by signing up for a year
with a link on screen or in the
description below you won't find a
better deal in streaming